also I think what is very interesting  and very bizarre to me is the timing of  all of this Andrew Tate is officially  one of the most influential men of all  if not the most influential person of  2022 more search than Kim Kardashian  this man has an incredible level of  influence and power and his message goes  against the mainstream it goes against  the establishment he's inspiring young  people to wake up take personal  responsibility and not be a slave to the  government not be a slave to the nine to  five not be a slave to the establishment  and if you have people waking up and  leaving the Matrix as he likes to put it  and not being reliant on government well  then that's bad for government because  then the population is awake they're not  as easy to control and not as easy to  brainwash so Andrew is inspiring people  to think for themselves and really just  turn against the establishment it's no  surprise to me that he's been shut down